okay guys psychobabble here with Kanye
and we are going to play project x 13
which we already did the first test this
is the advanced test watch out for laser
tripwires build ruin our day okay so
it's the same one as the first task but
just strip bars really see the first one
check out the last night fighting over
oh [ __ ]
sneaking done fighting now I can I
cessation of hostilities complete wow
this [ __ ] again oh this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] Oh everyone's like dad that's
easy what the fly [ __ ]
this is how you say especially after you
[ __ ] killed everyone okay right great
great in a psycho babble always happy
what the flying [ __ ] test data processed
or more updated to version 1.2 I said it
online guys are more let's just check
and maybe another one
expertly experts tough test if you
thought the lasers were bad wait till
you see the proximity not like it let's
say that says Dallas the [ __ ] are their
proximity mines oh [ __ ] we just got a
cape metal bed we just gotta keep movin
ah shut no no no no no no no no don't we
back we triggered a mine if you go back
to the terminal to restart the test I'll
do better next time jesús
okay test data processed for more
updated to version 1.2 auto subnet
online chase s alleble up oh we got a
lot of nice things here alright everyone
haha mask risk how do ya head
okay calm down right
this is the expert staff chest if you
thought the lasers were baguette wait
till you see the public service is no
there no reason for snake eggs out just
like you a lot easier okay got oh [ __ ]
okay okay did it a processed and we're
updated to version one point I did they
did horse you take it synced to users
physiology wow thanks see thanks guys
okay I raise one where's all the way oh
she could she there's a lot of good [ __ ]
here okay test selection this is the
robot compliance test if you sneak up on
a robot you can disable it it's so easy
even i can't mess up how the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do it I don't have a stealth
x
too bad we triggered a mine if you go
back to the terminal to restart the test
I'll do better next time can I just
shoot the [ __ ]
I machine I can find a stealth boy need
to calibrate these little senses mmhmm
yeah yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] i can turn all off i'm kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I didn't I can [ __ ] lie craig the
task then there What's Up boy Oh fresh
apples [ __ ] yeah I think that's a good
plan who do you think is cuter dr. Klein
we're dr. burroughs dr. Klein don't make
me choose that's all I need a [ __ ]
staff bye baby yeah yeah yeah father
Moore pack of cigarettes like that's the
part that is like bringing down the game
there's not enough stuff boys and
cigarettes and now like I tried I try to
make it a fair game but I just go around
sigh all the robots real quick Oh a lot
of proxy when you did that cuz I gotta
admit I did a pretty good job like
hiding them like they just like all over
the [ __ ] floor
okay well I know there's one where the
no time to cessation of hostilities
complete ok South boy stuff but not now
there's not ok one through here check in
here
[ __ ] empty how do i do that what I
what I do that to myself it's a cat all
need to open it but I do i do that's a
flaw of mine I recognize my own flaws ok
I think I know there's a [ __ ]
everybody's yet destroy the robots real
quick opinion outs are like really good
for you no not good for you no fresh
potato and a cat that applied
here's that shet hello daddy ID oh
that's too bad those robots would
normally help defend us and the facility
if we're bad guys dealt with tell me
usually I know the [ __ ] proximity
right here there is another one Boris
yea though i know that's shocking one
around here approximately what is that
oh that's an apple I'll take that
[ __ ] love for it I'm a survivalist
okay I should try taking the test now
now that like everyone's like [ __ ]
destroyed actually i'll go up real quick
kill these robots hey can't yet there's
more robots right Ready Steady ID I can
hear them how the [ __ ] are they okay
[ __ ] oh that's all he's on the other
side right I just saw something for like
that [ __ ] was it
I hear him what I [ __ ] you god it's
gotta be here [ __ ] broke my leg at
son ok now let's do it this is the robot
compliance test if you sneak up on a
robot you can disable it it's so easy
even i can't mess up
how can I do that we said everything
they [ __ ] reset everything that is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
here about here maybe we're going to
save of the mines quick rate or find
another way past your [ __ ] ass last
packet and another South boy a tough
[ __ ]
you